bonjour liés et que l'on merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
vous faites un parti des maires et qui
ont signé un arrêté pour que les
commerces non essentiels puisse rester
ouvert qu'est ce qui a motivé votre
décision
écoutez tout simplement le bon sens
parce que les médecins aient beaucoup de
médecins en tout cas dit ce qu' il y a
beaucoup moins de risques a attrapé le
virus en faisant ses courses en une dans
un commerce de proximité dans une petite
boutique que dans un hypermarché où vous
croisez des centaines de personnes c'est
du bon sens très simple surtout que les
commerçants de proximité se sont adaptés
avec la première vague du virus
ils ont déjà pris beaucoup de mesures
c'est à dire que vous le voyez bien
d'ailleurs
quand vous arrivez à l'entrée de votre
boutique habituel il ya du gel
il ya un masque vous met à disposition
si jamais vous en avez pas il ya des
distances par ailleurs qu'ils soient
respectés avec des marquages au sol
il ya aussi beaucoup de commerces
maintenant qui régulent le flux qui
feront jamais plus de deux ou trois
personnes chez les libraires ou chez les
marchands de chaussures est donc tout
simplement beaucoup moins risque
sanitaire à aller faire ses courses dans
un commerce de proximité que dans un
hypermarché
alors moi m'ont arrêté cette année a été
de bon sens pour cette raison la une
plusieurs maisons typiques et des
raisons économiques
c'est à dire que nos commerces
militaires ont déjà beaucoup souffert
ces derniers mois
si on veut qu'il meure et bien on
continue comme ça voilà deux mois je
veux qu'ils vivent
moi je dis vive et pour qu'ils vivent il
vous permet de faire leur travail
ce que disait jean marc sylvestre juste
avant et je le rejoins sur ce point il
faut leur permettre de travailler il
faut leur permettre de vivre simplement
leur travail ce que j'espère est ce
qu'ils attendent
mais encore une fois on a affaire à des
gens responsables les commerçants sont
des personnes responsables
ils savent n'ont pas l'air envie de
frapper le virus ne vous inquiétez pas
quand vous rentrez dans une boutique
les mesures sont prises et il ya tout ce
qu'il faut et en réfère sanitaires pour
aller faire ses courses en sécurité là
bruno le maire parlait hier je cite à
deux maires irresponsables c est
l'humain qui comme vous ont décidé de
prendre un arrêté pour que les commerces
restent ouverts
vous vous sentez responsable il ya trop
sable alors moi je vais vous dire je me
sens le plus responsable du monde les
mes collègues maires compris la vérité
que moi ce sens je crois très
responsable
on a fait ça pourquoi on a fait ça
justement de l'intérêt général de notre
population
on a fait ça parce que il ya encore une
fois moins de risques sanitaires aller
faire ses courses chez les petits
commerçants
pourquoi il ya deux fois moins de cas
aujourd'hui en allemagne alors que les
commerces de proximité sont ouverts
elles seront s'est posé la question
elle en quoi expliquer moi en quoi il
serait plus risqué d'aller faire ses
courses chez votre libraire chez votre
marchand de vêtements chez votre
marchand de cosmétiques ce que vous
voulez que dans les hypermarchés emploi
dès que l'on explique moi j'ai pas
rencontrer encore là seul médecin
aujourd'hui
kim est dit que c'était plus dangereux
c'était dangereux d'aller faire ses
courses je dois vivre les petits
commerces
alors les fédérations de commerçants
seront reçus à bercy cette semaine pour
étudier une possible réouverture de
leurs magasins à partir du 12 novembre
prochain est ce que c'est déjà trop tard
selon vous sait jamais trop tard il faut
tout ce qu'on peut faire pour sauver le
commerçant maintenant vous savez nos
commerçants les ont passé leurs
commandes
ils ont des stocks il comptait beaucoup
sur le web mois de décembre pour
j'allais dire se remettre un petit peu à
flot par rapport à ce qu'ils ont vécu
ces derniers mois
donc tout ce qu'on pourra faire pour les
sortir de là il saura faire et je vais
vous dire moi j'ai pris un arrêté
voyez pour que du commerce reste ouvert
à hier samedi mais commerces sont restés
ouverts y compris les commerces non
alimentaires y avait du monde dans les
magasins ça s'est très bien passé on l'a
respecté les les gestes barrières on a
respecté les flux les commerçants pu
vivre les clients ont fait leurs courses
et tout s'est très bien passé
bon ben ça on peut renouveler et j'ai
oublié mon arrêté il a été attaqué par
la préfecture il sera jugé aujourd'hui
je pense
il ya très peu j'ai très peu de chances
que l'on arrêté soit maintenue il va
être cassée par le juge c'est une
évidence que ça a été cassée dans les
autres communes bon mais je vais vous
dire au moins ce qu'on aura fait sera
interdit de faire bouger les lignes et
quand j'ai entendu hier le ministre de
l'économie
ou quand j'ai entendu hier soir le pôle
ministre dira finalement on va peut-être
pas fermé pendant un mois mais on revoit
dans deux semaines il n'est plus dans le
sport on verra je me dis que
qu'on fait est utile que ce qu'on fait
au moins le mérite de faire bouger les
lignes
voilà donc je moi je veux dire les
jeunes jeu de mes voeux de tous mes
voeux je suis pour une illuminée voix
500 pour les discussions et pour une
évolution de la situation de tous mes
voeux j'appelle ça si c'est dans une
semaine c'est une semaine sans qu'un
jour si cette saison 15 jours mais de
grâce de grâce du pérou 4 autant vous
avez très certainement rencontrer un des
commerçants dans votre ville qui sont
pour la plupart j'imagine pour la
réouverture de leur commerce
est-ce que vous avez aussi rencontré des
des clients et que distille mais les
clients auraient coûté était trop tôt il
fallait présent à dire samedi pour voir
un peu comment ça s'est passé ou de 10
des commerçants heureux d'ouvrir
je me souviendrai avec passé chez le
libraire chez sheila ou du coiffeur chez
un marchand de chaussures c'est un
garçon de traite à porter pour hommes où
je croisais un deux clientes appuis
seront encore une fois s'était régulé et
très bien organisés près tout le monde
était content voilà les hyérois été le
web pourra faire leurs courses les
commerçants étaient heureux de pouvoir
vendre leurs produits et les pluies tout
ça s'est fait en direct de sanitaires
parfaite très a subi très clair encore
une fois avec toutes les garanties
nécessaires et c'était très dur oui bien
sûr je vais vous dire bien sûr les
commerçants attendent l'ouverture c'est
une évidence mais les haines les
citoyens aussi donc on sait que nos
citoyens ont besoin aussi de ce petit
lien social vous allez pouvoir y faire
leurs courses de pouvoir aller choisir
le bon livre chez leur libraire pouvez
le commander sur amazon
bien sûr que j'attends que ça les gens
merci beaucoup olivier à tout le monde
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur arte
plonge rappelle que vous êtes maire
divers droite de la commune de yerres
dans l'essonne merci beaucoup